today I'm going to be talking about
several Wolfram cloud related
technologies all with the common theme
how they can be used in a real world
application specifically this device
here in the Amazon echo now you come to
a conference like this or you look at
some of our promotional webpages you
exposed to an almost bewildering variety
of cloud technologies and it can be hard
to know where to start what's useful for
what etc so I think it's very useful to
see a concrete application and how some
of these technologies fit together to
solve problems and create interesting
applications I hope that the echo
provides an engaging example for that so
let's meet the echo it's really you can
think of it as something similar to Siri
as it's a personal assistant one
advantage that has over Siri is that
Alexa is always on but the most
important thing about the echo as far as
I'm concerned is that it has a
completely open programming model amazon
lets you extend the capabilities of the
echo by writing your own simple rest
style web services and this is that the
killer feature for me this is the reason
i bought the echo I it's poking around I
thought this might be interesting said
well I went to their website or they got
a whole SDK is like I knew right away
that this would be a great application
for Wolfram cloud stuff that you could
write some very very interesting things
with the laser cloud you know I think
that I wonder if Apple will have to open
up Syrian response the competition like
this because it's really useful to be
able to to extend this thing so let's
meet the echo here now the device is
called the echo but the voice and the
personality in the echo was named alexa
and that's the word you use to wake it
up and talk to it so i will often call
the thing alexr refer to it variously as
Alexa or the echo night I've turned her
off for the moment because it's very
sensitive to hearing her name so if you
say are talking about alexis is
constantly waking up and complaining
that she doesn't understand what you're
asking
she said you know the computer how has
nothing on Alexa you whisper her name in
the back corner she'll wake right up so
I'm going to turn her on here yeah it's
only way so Alexa what's going on in the
world here's your Flash briefing in NPR
news from tune in no from NPR news in
Washington on korva Coleman all right so
he just musics you can link to all sorts
of services like that has all sorts of
information like Alexa tell me about
Canada Alexa tell me about Canada Canada
is a country consisting of ten provinces
in 3 territories in the northern part of
the continent of North America doesn't
it but you didn't know that and the
thing about Alexa that is really the
game changer for me as I said before is
it it's always on just the fact that I
can just turn my head and say something
ask something I don't have to do
anything it really that one little
difference it makes all the difference
in the world as far as I'm concerned all
right so some of the technology will be
talking about we talk about instant
api's that is these api functions as you
can do blowing to the cloud and that's
really the main technology will be using
i'll show some applications with their
wolf and development platform just you
know the web interface that will be
using at times we'll talk about the wolf
amount for api we'll talk about some new
publish-subscribe functionality that's
coming to Mathematica we're talking
about deployed notebooks and report
generation which is an example of a
scheduled tasks in the cloud and then
probably very briefly the some use of
the cloud mobile app ok all right so now
let's talk about and we're here to
create our own Alexis skills they're
called skills in the in the world of
Amazon terminology so how do you how
does this whole thing work so there's
three actors in this there's the elect
the echo itself amazon some server
sitting somewhere and then the Wolfram
cloud is where we're going to play now
we're going to be of course you
wolfram cloud to deploy these Alexis
skills but you don't have to obviously
use the Wolfram cloud you could use any
your own private web server your own web
hosting service that you want to if you
want to use some technology other than
you know Wolfram language and Amazon
itself makes their own service available
for you know Java or JavaScript
development few want to write you web
services in that way alright so step one
is you deploy your web service to the
Wulfen clatter the things in blue are
the things that you have to do as a
program you deploy your web service to
the Wulfen cloud I mean we will talk
about all the details of these things
later of course so that's like your
cloud deploy of API function blah blah
then you have to define and register
your skill with the amazon developer
portal so you have to tell amazon about
you know the parameters of this alexus
skill so here's an example maybe it
let's say you've written some skill
called daily quotations and so here's
the flow of events the user says you
know esque daily quotations for today's
saying so that goes to the Amazon server
now you don't care about this as a
developer I don't care know anything
about this first step of the link i
don't really care about Alexis
communication with Amazon I only care
about the right hand side here Amazon's
communication with me and the Wolfram
cloud so ask daily quotations for this
I'm saying and then amazon sends to some
URL that you have told it about it sends
an Alexa request and this is just a big
package of Jason or actually kind of a
small package of Jason
so then your rule from cloud API will
have to handle this Jason it sends back
in the lecture response which is another
little bundle of Jason and then the
Amazon server sends back to the echoes
you know the result in echoecho speaks
it so it's what happens here on the
Wolfram cloud side your responsibility
is to handle this incoming bundle of
Jason with various information in it and
to create this outgoing bundle of Jason
with various information okay so very
simple so let's talk a little bit about
what an Alexis skill looks like or what
you know the steps you have to go
through you have to define your voice
interface and there's two aspects to
this there's the the intent schema and
there's a set of sample utterances now
I'm going to go through this quickly you
don't really need to care about the
details that's on this stuff but it's a
little interesting to kind of understand
how this stuff works so so this is an
example from the developer website a
very frivolous example of a horoscope
application horoscope skill so let's say
I want to write a horoscope skill and
every skill will have certain they're
called intense there's like actions that
you might want to take so this
horoscopes girl has to intense you can
ask to get a horoscope and oh you can
ask for you know get your lucky numbers
for the day very very valuable
application by the way so and then so
you define this is how you define the
intense and the if essentially the
arguments they take so the slots here
are the things that you feel and so you
might say something like asked you know
horoscopes to get horse you know get my
horoscope or something and that's Matt
to this intent you'd say get the
horoscope for virgo or something right
and so Virgo would be the sign slot and
then that's and this thing you know this
type list of size that's a user-defined
types you can define your own set of
types obviously listed list of signs
would be defined as the set of zodiac
signs
and you could ask for a sign in you know
a date so what's the horoscope virgo on
you know July seventh or something and
that's the date type so anyway that you
simply define your scheme up in tons and
then you define some sample utterances
and this is the not really tricky part
but where you put the most thought so
this is where you you tell Alexa what
you're going to be saying that it should
map to certain intense so so what is the
horoscope for sign here this is what I
would say to Alexa you know this part
right here what is the horoscope for
virgo say and that this line tells Alexa
that if I say what is the horoscope for
virgo that should map to the get
horoscope intent which is which is to
find a bum so yeah I said your name so
typically you'll have a very long list
of these things because you want your
users to be able to have a wide variety
of things that they might say to
activate this intent you don't want to
force them to say very precise set of
words so you can see they've got various
ways get me my horoscope or what is the
horoscope or you might you might if you
had this for real you would have a whole
bunch of these like you tell me the
horoscope for blank kind of thing so
that's what some sample utterances might
look like and then so so I know you
don't care about this or not I'm not
going to go through it at all but so
this is what Amazon sends you this
bundle of Jason and and you can see that
there's the information in here you the
intent at the bottom here is get
horoscope and tangent it fills in the
slots sign and the value so obviously
when you're writing your web service
that responds to this Jason you're going
to have to you look up the you know you
want to know the name of the intent get
horoscope and you'll want to know Virgo
you'll be picking that out from this
bundle
and so you know of course mathematica
the Wolfram language can import Jason
very easily I just ran that simple
little import just to see it just
returns into some nested set of
associations so fine I mean I'm done I
mean this is the first thing I did when
I went to the website eyes okay fine I
got some sample Jason reported it you
see what it looks like the rest is just
details teasing apart this association
to get all the information that Amazon
sends you is quite straightforward and
then the ears of Jason typical Jason
response maybe this is what you need to
send back to amazon so you will have to
create Jason that looks like this and
Wolfram language also has a very simple
way to to turn an association back into
Jason export does that for you so you'll
just build some Association you export
Jason and something like this will come
out and of course this right here is the
you know the output speech part of the
response is the thing where you would be
filling in what you want the echo to say
all right fine so let's talk about
instant API so now we're going to talk
about the details of writing the the
service that Amazon will be talking to
the running in the Wolfram cloud so the
welcome call it makes it very easy to
deploy Wolfram language code in such a
way that can be accessed as a standard
rest style API in the web rest out just
means that you know the data is it's not
using soap or some complicated protocol
where you have a large set of you know
big payload that you have to deal with
it's it's a very simple concept so
here's an example you've seen this sort
of thing before a function that adds two
integers so you you know this first
argument API function is a list of
integer of slot names parameter names I
and J and their types integers so Wulfen
cloud automatically handles sort of
parsing an integer out of the data that
you
live of these parameters and then you
know pound actors pound J in a person
that's the block of code that is the
functionality that you're deploying on
the web just adding two arguments I mean
this is all you need to do and really
what goes in here and of course the
parameter types but what goes in there
is arbitrary piece of Wolfram language
functionality so it's it's this simple
to create some extremely powerful
complicated piece of functionality and
make it available on the web to any
caller from really any language or
environment so if i run this i get back
some cloud object and so this URL this
is the URL that i can use to access this
so if i click on this my browser
launches so i click on this you can't
see this oh my gosh you get some error
well that's just because I didn't define
the I and J parameters I'm going to put
this in the URL I could use this form to
add them but I would just say you know ?
i equals 2 and J equals 3 so if I fix
the URL then you in the fire upper left
is a very small five all right you get a
result back it's very small result all
right so I've just used a web browser to
access this URL but of course I use Java
any programming language I want any
environment lets you call these sorts of
AP is so in just one very small line of
Wolfram language code I've deployed a
piece of functionality that i wrote to
any client anywhere in a very very
simple way
all right now there's one complication
here which is that the web api call that
amazon sends doesn't have named
arguments like a typical call you're not
you know it doesn't have I you know it
doesn't have input equals blah in the
URL or in the in the post body it just
has a block of Jason code so how do I
get a block of Jason code out of the
HTTP request well there's a function
called HTTP request data if you put this
inside your API function you can get
various aspects of the HTTP request you
can get the headers or in this case the
body so this is a little tidbit that's
not obvious because almost all the
examples of API functions have these
named arguments but if you just need to
get the entire body of the post request
as a single string you can just say HTTP
request data a body so these api
functions that are created you won't
really see them because i've written a
package that simplifies all this but
inside they they get the jason by
calling HTTP request data of body
alright so now let's create a simple
echo skill using the Wolfram cloud so
this is going to be one that just echoes
what the user says back and this is
actually quite useful because I mean I
created this as a testing thing was its
sfe useful to know exactly what Alexa
here's and what words she leaves out or
doesn't leave out so there's only one
intent this is my intense game is only
one in ten called echo intent I'm naming
it input and the type is literal and so
what this is what literal means any old
string of text so what this silly
looking set of sample utterances means
is that I just put in the words in here
like what is the longest input that
business are just gibberish all right I
just need to have a you know one to ten
words or want to end words in this thing
so if I just had you know what is
here then the service probably wouldn't
recognize a three-word statement see so
I just put it I could make this longer
if I wanted and then I could say even
longer strings to Alexa cyl anyway so i
write this sample utterances and intense
schema so I've deployed well haven't
done that yet actually that's all right
so let's deploy the API function so we
see needs Alexa I've already defined
this alright so the endpoint here this
is the URL that I'm going to its been
truncated here but did I that I need to
tell amazon this is what I'm deploying
my my API function to this URL and I've
already created this cloud object
address in the past so when I deployed
my Lexus kill I want to redeploy to the
same URL every time because that's the
URL that Amazon knows about it's going
to call this skill on so anyway this is
my function if this is the function that
does the work and this as you can see
there's this alexa response i've written
this alexa package to make this stuff
simple but it's a very simple pad you're
just like a page or two of code so i can
just say alexa you know the output
speech is the is the thing that you know
the echo will say back and gets lot
that's just extracts the thing coming in
so this just returns the input that was
coming in and sends it back as the
output speech and then I'd up this
function deploy Alexis skill which is
the thing that that deploys the skill to
that end point so now the the API
function is running in the cloud so what
I would do now is I would go to Anna's
on this is their web developer website
my list of skills and so if i go to echo
input it's going to probably fail here
because i have two real aughh in but
let's just take a few clicks
all right so anyway I you go here here's
where you provide I guess you can't see
this because this incredibly smaller it
doesn't matter i provide the name of the
my scale and version in this string down
here this is the URL that cloud object
address that I deployed my skill to so
this is the address that Alexa that any
amazon server will talk to when the
skill is invoked and then the
interaction model this is where I put my
sample utterances and my intense schema
and then I just then i'm done i fill
those things in and this is how i
register my skill with amazon alright so
let's try it so I I have to say the name
of my application which is echo input so
I say Alexa ask echo input to repeat
what I said repeat what I said okay so
there we have it I just wrote basically
one line of Wolfram language code
deployed it to the Wolfram cloud went to
the website register the skill and in
once that registering and skill is a
one-time operation i can i can change
this all i want here let's just say if i
want this thing to say hello instead of
echoing what i said i can just redefine
that redeploy and i say alexa ask echo
input to repeat what i said hello
just to prove that this is all alive
let's leave it the way it was now one
thing you'll notice is that if when you
talk to the echo you have to say to
watch you get confused if I say Alexa
ask echo input say something hmm I can't
find the answer to the question I heard
yeah you see it needs that word to you
really have to phrase it as a if I say I
have to say Alexa ask echo input to say
something Alexa ask echo input to say
something say something you have to have
the word to there and you can also say
Alexa tell echo input to say something
say something when I'm testing I found
quite a few times I forget to put that
like first little word that makes a real
sentence out of it and she gets confused
alright so there we have it we've
created our first echo skill and
deployed it to to the to the echo and
everything else is just how how fancy do
you want to get with your with your
skills so what's the first thing that
anyone does when they you know start
developing application you build a game
right so let's let's play a game the
license plate game so the point is that
you this works great in new york state
where i grew up because almost every
card a three letter sequence and its
license plate so you're driving along
you're bored you car goes by get the
three-letter sickness from the license
plate and the ideas that come up with
words that have those three letters in
exactly that order now that we're they
want to be consecutive in the word but
they have to be in that order there's
three points to be had for each license
plate one point for the first person to
come up with a word one person one point
for the person who comes up with the
shortest word and one person there's
another point for a word that has the
letters consecutively so I thought of
this game there would be perfect example
for the Wolfen cloud because America has
a dictionary lookup a
it's a full English dictionary it's very
simple to ask you know to generate three
letter sequences at random and look up
fine if they match words etc etc etc so
I wrote a simple imitation so let's
let's play now the planes game for real
here so I people need to I want people
to participate Alexa ask license plate
game to start another round the letters
are n r f
come on Alexa s license plate game to
give the answer the shortest word is
sunroof there are no consecutive words
son Rubens good one good one okay won't
let's play that's the game
implementation it really need now that
we've played it you can see there's
three intense there's we can ask Alexa
to start a new round we can ask it to
give us the answer we can ask her to
repeat the letters and so here are some
of the utterances right so you can see I
can I want to have a lot of flexibility
in what i can say any of these things
intellectual giving the answer so I just
write a you think about various ways as
you want users to be able to interact
and you so here's the code and I just
want to show you about how short it is
cheating a little bit there's a few
functions here like in a license plate
game package generate letters these are
relatively short functions I just I
don't really have it in line for no
particular reason so there's just about
that much code is needed and then we
here's the deploy Alexis skill so deploy
Alexis kill you just you map various
intense two functions that are their
handlers for those intense that's simple
right I just I just say that the launch
which is then when I say ask it to
launch license plate game that starts a
new round it's the same thing as asking
for a new round the answer intent maps
to the give answer function so it's very
simple I just associate each of the
intense with a mathematical function
that handles that intent okay alright so
now let's look at another example which
is Wolfram Alpha spoken answers or why
should Siri have all the fun people
probably know that for a long time Siri
has given spoken result answers that
come from Wolfram Alpha and we have a
you know business relationship with
Apple that made that possible
math teachers available new love map API
although it is an extra cost feature so
that's not if you're just doing free
alpha API queries you can't get spoken
results you have to have a special app
ID that lets you do that I have such an
app ID so i can write that but if you
were doing this for real you'd have to
talk to us the business development all
right so anyway this is what a call to
the wolf's mouth the API might look like
URL execute is just a convenient
function in Mathematica for for fetching
the URL that allows you to specify the
parameters in the serve symbolic way and
and so you you say spoken result goes to
true in the arguments that's that's the
magic that lets you get back spoken
results and this is you get back some
XML thing back this is what it looks
like in Mathematica you know you don't
really care about any of this stuff but
this one element here at the bottom the
spoken result element is the thing that
has what you're looking for and you see
the sample text the answer is for this
is the thing that Siri reads out when
you ask Siri what you know two plus two
is I don't actually know if Siri goes to
Wolfram Alpha for two plus two but for
other queries it does alright so that's
I just need to write something that
makes queries like this to Wolfram Alpha
and it'll get back XML like this I just
have to pick out pick apart the XML to
find this sample text all right that's a
piece of cake the implementation there's
only one intent which is to ask a
question I called it the query intent
and again here's just gibberish strings
of you know i can ask queries that are
up to about 14 words so anyway I don't
know you don't care about this i don't
i'm not going to talk about the code at
all but this is the only thing i had to
write this do query function this
implements the entire thing just simply
gets the users speech it form late say
wolf amount of ABI call makes the call
picks apart the spoken result and sends
it back to to amazon and then it can be
deployed just like that I've already
done that of course
so anyway let's so let's let's play
around with that so so I say Alexa ask
wolframalpha how many calories in a cup
of broccoli the answer is about 26.9
dietary calories know that okay Alexa
ask wolframalpha what is the mass of a
boson
it looks like the answer is about 1330
Giga electron volts for speed of light
squared you know that right Alexa ask
Wolfram Alpha to integrate sine X from 0
to PI it looks like the answer is to
don't get too excited LexA isn't great
at interpreting spoken math that's a
pretty simple example if you give it
some more things I mean you could
probably try to clean up what Alexa
thinks you said you could write some
code to clean it up but it's not graded
it understanding spoken math so there we
have it we've written we've turned Alexa
into you know the name again Alexis
Gnostic turned her into the same
capabilities as Siri has with wolf's
mouth and that we that was you saw that
was the entire amount of code that was
needed to do that all right fine what I
really want though is visual output
and I think actually this is a really
killer application for the echo I think
that I mean voice responses are great
but I think that if you have in
conjunction with a screen this had some
inexpensive screen mounted on your wall
in your kitchen or something you're
living them and you say something to
Alexa and Alexa can put something up on
a screen I think that's really really
interesting use case and Alexa does have
turn around talking about her sorry
we're going to talk about or now it's
okay you know you can send these little
cards to your phone for example the
Alexa app on your phone so it into voice
output you can send a little card that
appears on your phone but currently the
feature that it's just pure text is
nothing else you can't send a clickable
link you certainly can't send a picture
so and i know that amazon will change
that because it's like the number one
requested thing on the developer forums
but right now the app sort of visual non
voice output from alexa is just trivial
string of text that's the only thing you
can do so but i like to imagine you know
a screen in my living room or something
and i can talk to it and it gets a
visual output so let's see how you might
do that so if i want to do visual output
i do need to push something at and i'm
going to use mathematica as the client
that does the display it doesn't have to
be that but of course I'm running
Mathematica so I'm going to use that and
it's very easy to set up so i need to
the cloud needs to push something at my
copy of mathematica so how can I do that
well we have this new feature which is
not in Mathematica yet but it's coming
very soon it will probably be available
i'm guessing as an automatic update in
between releases i'm not sure about that
it's this publish and subscribe notion
or channels as we call them if people
might be familiar with this concept that
goes way back and computer science the
notion of like a message broker or
something where you have some some
server some piece of software sitting
somewhere that you can publish things to
and other people can other programs can
subscribe to that server and they can be
notified when people publish things to
them
and so we've created a simple
implementation of that idea not going to
execute these things because these
things are already running but so we
have this notion of this create channel
function so I can create a channel it's
a name thing on some server this is our
server channel broker to Wolfram cloud
com so I create a channel with a certain
name and then i can send things to that
channel and then other clients can
subscribe to that child they can listen
on that channel so when i push something
at that Sun something to that channel
they will be notified so this channel
receiver function is that is the
mathematical function that will be
executed when the receiver gets the
message so then i can say China listen
so if I said if I executed this line
which is already running that would set
mathematic up in a state where it's in a
background thread waiting sort of
waiting for something to come in and
respond to it so this is the magic this
listen thing this channel listen it's
the magic that puts mathematic into a
state where it's ready to have things
pushed at it all right so I have no idea
what this receive function channel
receiver function does so let's just
make a simple definition for this is
something it's just going to print the
arguments I don't I don't know what it
takes so let's just so let's just try it
we say channel send to ch42 I guess I
didn't execute this so if i say channel
send i get some message I but so looks
like nothing happened but because this
came because this came in a background
computation it shows up in the messages
window so there it is this is just my
receive function executing I printed it
things out so I can see that my receiver
function gets this association with
various elements in it but you see raw
data goes to 42 so the raw data element
is the thing that I sent so I just need
to write function when I want to write a
receiver function I just pick out the
raw data thing that's the thing
the other side sent all right so let's
so i'm going to write a new receiver
function it's going to put up a display
no you don't we'll see what this doesn't
it say so now that I've done this set
something up in Mathematica to happen
win with so now let's try this already
deployed the this wolf map is already
doing this okay so we say Alexa ask
wolfram alpha what is the 15th prime
number the answer is 47 there we have it
so you can't really see that because
it's blown up with tile things but I
just I asked Mathematica to respond to
this message coming in by opening a new
window zooming it and you know executing
the wolf's mouth of function so so this
is the idea this thing is sitting in my
living room and when I I asked both my
offer for things they could send me an
answer back but it can also put up a
screen of information so anyway this is
just a sample of the sort of thing that
you could do to it really enable some
powerful visual output from from the
echo so let's try just for kicks see if
I can break this Alexa well that Alexa
ask Wolfram Alpha to integrate sine X
from 0 to PI try one more time the
answer is approximately 15 points 7 08
there we go it's actually not incredibly
interesting Wolfram how the output for
this I thought it might be more useful
but any case so there we have it visual
display from from Wolfram Alpha you know
without your hands-free visual display
from from a Alexis skill using the
mathematic as the sort of the client to
do this so I'm not going to
show the code in any case all right so
then so finally I'll talk about this
time tracker app now I'm sitting in my
office axes in my office and I think you
know one thing I've never done and
there's various time tracker
applications and sometimes Wolfram wants
to know if people spend their time for
progress reports and things and I have
never been able to keep any kind of
discipline with keeping track of when I
work on things it's just too much effort
you have to go and click some even just
having to go click something is too much
it sit down and start working on
something I don't I never think or have
time to go do something to say okay now
I'm working on project x I thought Lex
is sitting right here it would be pretty
easy just to say you know I'm working on
this project now or I've squished to a
different project things like that so
that maybe i can write a little time
track that this could be actually useful
it's it's a perfect example of a be
always on nature of Alexis so my goal is
to use her in my office to help me keep
track of time spent so voice interface
would be things like you know tell time
tracker to start project XYZ or you know
tell time tracker I'm switching to some
other project or or you know tell time
tracker I'm taking your break or I'm
going to sleep something these were all
things that would so she's running now
and I so Alexa ask time tracker to list
my projects you have four projects with
names meeting talk cloud for 136 and
Colonel forking right so cloud 4.36 is
you know those are numbers we use to
keep track of projects in our project
tracking system now this data is not
real I actually used this a while back
when I was first to billing it but I
haven't I don't have any real data for a
while so I kind of put in some some fake
data just for sample but the idea is
that when I could go and went to a
meeting say i would say i'm going to a
meeting so you can ask things like so
Alexa ask time tracker how much time I
spent on project meeting last week you
have spent seven point two five hours on
project meeting so you know mathematic
is very good with me
sorts of computations I just sit down
and I said and going to a meeting i'm
coming out of a meeting and it keeps
track and I can ask for things like how
much time I spent in but what I also
want is I want a visual display I wanted
obviously just voice output for
something is it's not really going to be
suitable for understanding how I'm
spending my time I want some sort of
visual display so how would that work
the idea is that I want to use a report
generation feature of the cloud so at
the end of every operation that changes
the data you know I'm starting a swish
into a project I want to automatically
generate a report that I can view in a
web browsers maybe you're on my phone
that will show me some maybe some plot
or various ways of representing the
stadium horse mathematic is very good at
visualization so i can create all sorts
of fancy plots and reports now one
reason i want to do this in a scheduled
task i don't want when i say i'm
stopping project x I don't want the
voice interface to delay while this
project report generation happens
because it could be time consuming and I
don't also don't want there to be a
delay when the user when I go to the
page I don't want to have to do work
then I want to generate this thing sort
of in the background so I scheduled a
task that runs in the cloud to generate
this report and then when I go to it
it's all ready for me to view so this is
the you know the Wolfram programming you
know development platform website over
here you know in my cloud files I have
various files have created an in reports
this is where my reports are stored I've
created a template a template notebook
which is trivially simple this is not
even close to a real user interface but
create a notebook that just has title
and this little slaw here I don't know
if you've ever used the notebook
template feature this is just the
notebook template feature that's been in
Mathematica for a little while now i
just have a slot called plot and so this
is the thing that's going to be filled
in replaced by data when the report is
generated so this is the template for
the report generation some process runs
which fills in the slot values in
juice as a result notebook so I just
created this just here in this interface
by adding things and typing and I've
created this file right now I don't have
time to talk about this because it's a
little complicated but I've got this
there's a thing called a document
generator which is really just a fancy
type of scheduled task it's designed to
run you can run it manually or can run
at intervals in the cloud it takes a
file the template that was the file we
just saw that had that empty slot for
the plot it takes the source of the data
this is the data this is just a file
into which that you know plot goes to
some data that is the plot will will
live in that file it will simply run
that template with that data so my code
in the Wolfram in the Time Tracker app
writes out this template datum file
every time I change the data and then
when the report runs that gets merged
with that template to create a report
and then this is how I can so when I
don't I don't do this on the web I'm
just showing you what it looks like my
code runs this line my time tracker app
runs that line to generate the report so
the report doesn't it's scheduled this
none here is the default schedule it
doesn't ever run I could make it run
hourly if I want or something like that
but it doesn't run by itself at all i
have to it only runs manually when i
execute this so this is what i execute
inside my program elsewhere so anyway so
i can go here and i can click on this
and i can see you know open latest
report and it shows up now it opens in
this interface but if i change the URL
to www
you will open without all that framing
around it all right so and unfortunately
the plot which I spent so long crafting
beautifully doesn't look quite right in
the cloud I'm not sure whether it's
because the clouds running 10.2 and I'm
built this with 10.3 I could also be
some small issues with cloud graphics
rendering i'm not sure but in any case
here is my my time tracker report of
sort of a sort of a gantt type chart of
how i'm spending my time now oh shoot
I'm really running wrong but the idea
here is that I have a web page that I
can go to you know browser on a phone
whatever and I can see a report and I
could have multiple reports that
represent the state in various ways
deploy to the web so that from any
device or anytime I want I just go to
this page to see you know my time to
record data so if I was a commercial
developer and I was trying to create a
time tracker application to sell the
people of course I would want people to
be able to go and get reports this is an
example of you know how I could is a
trivial example of how I could create
and deploy these things okay so
so in conclusion I hope that been able
to you know enlighten you about some
ways that you can use the cloud
technologies I really do enjoy this
device I think people should look into
it I recommend getting one and in
conclusion I have the code this alexa
application pacolet that I wrote for
this will be available it's not really
polished yet but before long it'll be
available you can run this line packet
update of Alexa in your copy of
Mathematica if it works it's there if it
says there's no Packer called alexa I
haven't done it yet that's how you'll
know whether it's ready or not and then
of course this conference this notebook
is available from the website okay thank
you very much